okay so this is a heat signature I just
realized there is no reason to call this
heat signature outside of the fact that
it's just the movie they're gonna watch
well that's the whole movie it's great I
I guess I I just I wanted to say one
thing really quick oh yeah yes according
to the overall like wiki list and all
that stuff heat signatures supposed to
be the last episode of season two but as
per a lot of people on the forums and
whatnot they bring up a good point that
it's not a great season finale so I just
tossed it before the next ones because I
agree so yes it's a little out of order
so if this the season finales the next
one this season again there's so many
different orders I have no idea on the
DVD and okay well it's supposed to be
but okay um okay another Marceline
episode you get they go - are they
ghosts is that yes they go - Marceline
how's that paper scissor thing vampires
can't beat ghosts it's rough right paper
scissors no matter that I said oh yeah
okay that's right they can't beat that
we'll get to that in a second I was
really funny but they go to our house
which I forgot it's like this really
nice-looking how it's just in a case
like has a little Benson's pretty little
flower sits in a cave and to go in and
Marceline has these three friends are
ghosts I can't look like pac-man ghosts
and they finish a Kyrgyz show heat
signature which is this movie about
having a heat signature but they don't
have a heat signature and they decide
they want become vampires but Marceline
doesn't really want to turn with the
vampires so she sort of does the what
what the hell that we're here quickly
print yeah perfectly pleura right it
sort of like we put parsley in marijuana
and you know you see how your friend
reacts do you ever have that happen to
you you ever done that day one it's
funny sick see you've never heard of
that you just take you think parsley
crab love is like you know dodo is is
real stuff let's go let's go do you see
if they were like you know oh never you
know you're missing out on okay so
anyway it's like that don't do drugs
kids yeah do parsley
oregano that's what I think it was
oregano sorry about that
oregano parsley will not work as well it
doesn't it won't work as well but
regardless did you do with oregano you
don't know what you're missing Mansell
arias okay so alright so they want the
vampire she doesn't want to do it so she
pretends to turn into vampires and they
play all these little pranks on him just
seeing you know if they'll convince him
we're not the ghosts one take it too far
and they try to kill them Marceline
doesn't want them to die so she saves
them and then at the very end they find
out they're not vampire she comes in
almost about to save them but there's
just like nah I can't defeat ghosts what
does that mean a rock-paper-scissor
thing rock beats scissors scissors beat
paper paper beats Rock oh my gos beat
vampires is that it yeah oh okay light
like go serve it okay I got um but then
they're like too much parsley maybe
maybe you know you ramp up the oregano
in the parsley that's like the rolling
paper that's I can't believe never done
this it's great fun
but anyway so he says out but we haven't
seen a heat signature and a heat
signature and they watch the movie say
they'll eat the brains afterwards
remember this all started because they
jumped on the couch that was too solid
and I liked that that they just never
used the furnitures more just there for
decoration that whole house doesn't look
like a house she would have oh how did
she get that cuz I'm actually looking
for a place to live for a while right
and then she like how that happens to
work she found the cave and then because
she originally wanted their place
I forget how she'd get that house
remember Finn and Jake had to go find a
place and they ended up finding the cave
yeah
Marceline showed up and said this is my
cave as well know by me did she just
make the house herself then yeah okay
it's just 15 it so doesn't look like a
house she would Abby she sort of looks
like yo sort of like a rocker or
something like that you know it just you
what they like this pretty little purple
house that has like flowers and stuff it
just doesn't seem like I'm a metalhead
boy look or even act remotely like a
metalhead no but you don't have a house
that's purple and full of flowers
I just have a bunch of Christmassy stuff
all over the place I just assumed that
was Jory he's pretty much there you go
so when Marceline gets married they'll
make more sense um but ok let's actually
talk about the dama the so you're the
ones I am i rolling up parsley well and
now I'm not okay we're done Oh oh I
liked it I really like the fact that
Marceline was having fun with it and
going further but every once in a while
you noticed the ghosts wanted to do some
form of prank and she would get kind of
upset or annoyed or kind of like no I
don't like where this is going and she'd
pull it back you kind of get the idea
that especially when you first see her
that she was more aggressive and like
maybe before knowing them she totally
would let this fly you know upon her
death but because she does know them and
does like them she's like yeah let's
pull this back a bit and even the
friends are yeah like I'll come out what
happened to you used to be all about
this so yeah I started like that too but
at the same time they don't go they
still keep it in character cuz she comes
in as like oh yeah no I can't defeat
ghosts yeah just just sort of walks away
even at the end when they're watching
the movie thank you can we eat our
brains alright this is uncomfortable
yeah yeah after the movie it's like
she's still kind of doesn't care so it's
it's a nice sort of middle ground and I
just like stuff where somebody thinks
there's something and they're really not
and just seeing how far they'll go with
it um I I don't know I I just think that
stuff so he's funny um another minor
part I really liked is when she's about
to bite Finn and she lifts up his hood
and you see the hair starting to grow
back it's a little bit longer you know I
was gonna ask about that because yeah
that's right the hair was really long
but then he cut it right so it says
starting to grow no that makes sense
because I was trying to remember I get
so much happens on this show and to
remember like wait whatever with the
hair again and stuff so and again it's a
very minor thing that shows that time is
actually passing instead of like how
many other cartoon shows where some gets
a bad haircut or they get their head
next episode yeah yeah this is one where
it's like no he's actually slowly
growing his hair back it's not this
instantaneous well and this world feels
like you know you can come across these
characters anytime
and well for example they run across LSP
who is think it might be my favorite
really yeah maybe even more than tree
trunks because I realize anytime she
shows up I just start laughing that
voice is just so funny tonight beans no
I just sounded like The Venture Brothers
yeah oh my god I don't know why it
really cracks me up everything she it's
just such a funny voice um okay I have a
question for you Jory when Finn docked
over the beans you know Gimli went oh
why did you do that well the funny thing
is is she does this before lumpy Space
Princess actually goes I thought I was
missing something and I was like wait no
that was just being the forest do you
see her she's dirty she's so heavy oh my
god life is good I just found a can of
beans think about it she's excited about
beans this is all she has now she has
nothing who's gonna eat the beans what
is she gonna eat I think you've been
smoking some parts
wouldn't you be giving my wife one of
her people liking the most characters no
it's gorgeous huh no you're doing the I
can't do it sorry
personally no it's what every time she
shows up I just I start to giggle I'm
like okay that's a sign of a good
character where every time they're on
screen you start laughing oh but yeah no
it was fun it's that you know the
invisible scene no I'm sure other people
have done it but the first thing I think
of dear see Erik the Viking it's don't
think so it's directed by chariot Terry
Jones it has Tim Robbins and all this
stuff well this guy is convinced that
this cloak makes him invisible so he
puts it on be like oh where did I go
everybody's looking up strange and he
goes and he fights this battle with no
fear whatsoever because he thinks nobody
can see him you know keep it goes up to
guys like now do you see me now you
don't it runs away they're like what's
been and it's just great seeing this guy
who thinks nobody can see them and just
all the fear is gone um what have you
ever seen Amazon women on the moon no
there's a surprisingly I me how could I
miss that classic it's April 2nd Tucker
is playing to Kentucky Fried movie naked
yeah 10 Amazon women on the moon is a
the Zucker brothers and Jame roots as
far as I remember yeah but another says
now I want to see not office classic
it's the invisible man who's not
actually invisible he thinks he is so he
strips down butt-naked and he goes into
a bar two guys playing darts and he goes
up it's like oh I I don't know why that
stuff really makes me laugh I just cuz
the naked man running around a bar while
people just like it is well just when
someone thinks they're sound they're not
particularly when they think they're
handsome you think you're funny hey
sometime no I know I'm not funny okay I
make that very clear
oh well we'll never mind that was wrong
there you go you're often wrong I can
accept that
check please